One of Japan's World Heritage Sites has been destroyed by fire.
Flames tore through Shuri Castle on Thursday,...
...reducing the main hall of the over 500-year-old reconstructed landmark to a mere skeleton.
Firefighters on the southern island of Okinawa received the first call around 2:47 AM,...
...public broadcaster NHK said.
Local media quoted the city's mayor,...
...confirming that the castle's dragon monuments have been blackened...
...and said the north and south halls have been destroyed.
The wooden castle, painted bright red...
...and enclosed by curved stern walls, sits on a hill overlooking Naha.
It was due to be a scheduled stop on the 2020 Tokyo Olympic torch relay routes.
The city's fire department said that while the castle had exterior sprinkler systems,...
...its halls did not, as this wasn't required under local fire codes.
Shuri Castle has been destroyed by fire several times,...
...most recently in the Battle of Okinawa in 1945.
After World War II, it served as a university campus until the mid-1970s.
Once restored, it reopened as a national park in 1992...
...and was designated a World Heritage Site in the year 2000.